so jaime and i we've known each other
for um 15
20 years and we want to jump start the
social media thing
we want to issues come here and just
talk to you like you know what we have
going on
and just hear your thoughts cool a
little bit about me i met my wife at 14
met this guy 14 um you figured it all
out at 14. well
i started working at the front desk at
14. have i've had one job
one girlfriend uh she trained my wife
and i followed my passion
open up a business which you know i open
up gyms
so now we have 20 gyms globally we do
50 and you franchot you've got it so 50
is corporal thanks um with different
companies
and then the other 50 is like our
regular gyms that we own and operate
we have mexico different locations so
you have 10 gyms that you own and
operate
and 10 that are more more or less more
or less nine eight one
right you have eight that you own yeah
yeah so cabo
and then the bay area right and and the
rest are corporate wellness so
for example if you wanted to bring in
group style training
we specialize in that right so you build
gyms within organizations
correct and because basically our thing
is
like like you foster like what i thought
was it was broken so i started the gym
back in 2008
and i saw people getting engaged
becoming best friends everything
i figured there's nothing better for
your company i totally get these
connections in the same way
the way we work is building inside of
companies that whole concept
right i think of vayner that way yeah i
think vayner
building marketing departments within
companies is like a good idea
yeah and so so i get that for us we use
exercise way to break down the barrier
have the ceo working next door to the
intern
yep um so we in 2008 i opened our first
gym
a thousand square feet and then just
grew grew
no outside funding own and operated 100
ourselves we have 150 employees
uh i started competing at the crossfit
games 2008 won the crossfit games
is that right and then i competed eight
more times so
then so when you won the crossfit games
was that
the first time you got it kind of put on
publicly yeah
no so that was the second year of the
crossfit games i won it and after that
kind of catapulted a bunch of stuff
so i took a first a fifth i've done the
podium like multiple times been team usa
three times
i'm as decorated as you can get in that
area but i grew the business because at
the time when i got into crossfit
there was no money in it now because of
endorsements and stuff there's a lot
more money
which has been good for me to have but i
didn't have to rely on inside the
business
i understand so now we're at a place
here we are 10 years later
my daughter got diagnosed with leukemia
two years ago has changed everything
everything took a year off of travel i
used to travel 200 days a year
like you do i mean you probably do more
than that but i used to travel a lot
boom it just instantly made me change my
perspective
and i still obviously i was i was
blessed that good people are in the
business but i didn't travel anymore
now that she's doing better getting back
on my travel routine
and it's um you know i wrote a book
but i'm but i'm taking my time with it
you know i talked to tim ferriss a lot
about this he's just like dude you don't
have to write anything
wait until it's good and then put it out
the next couple months
but basically the theory about it is
this concept of amrap mentality
what kind of mentality amrap so amrap
fitness there's this thing called amrap
i was talking to jordan about it earlier
which is as many rounds as possible
and so the whole theory is like i think
in this day and age people get
distracted so easy
like they'll be talking to you but
they'll be on their phone they'll be
they'll be working but
at home with their kids and i think the
whole theory is
is that by incorporating this camera
where you am wrap whatever you're doing
like if i ask you as many push as you
can a minute
that's all you're focused on and so for
me
i was i opened the business i was
competing at the highest level i got
married i had two kids
started asking myself how do i balance
these different things but also like
thrive in them
and so the theory was just segmenting my
day and being present and focused on
whatever i was doing
but not being home because like the
story goes i'm preaching
i'm with my kids you're preaching
preaching the choir you're preaching in
the choir i mean i get
a lot of pushback from my work-life
balance i'm like cool you feel good
about yourself
that you're coming home at seven but
you're on your phone and like like
i'm complete divide and conquer that's
right i take
seven weeks of vacation which is a lot
by
workaholic standards but like that's how
i do it
that's right i call it like winning in
extremes like all i'm all in
and so like you're all in mentality like
obviously fall you know exactly
you know we know exactly you are and
everything
everything in your book is exactly what
alliance with my methodology life's cool
i believe to be ethical i believed it
like
and from what i hear about you like from
the different people i know know you
like it's not a front like who you are
you are yeah because you know some
people
of course i know yeah and and so anyways
this is why i like meeting people like
it only helps me in a lot of ways right
because it's just like the closer people
are the more the truth gets exposed
that's right and so for me it's like uh
you know again i
i share this because you're giving me a
framework you're giving me context it's
good these different things going on
create this constant gamer mentality so
is your is your
i'm listening and you can give me more
but as a quick first question
is your because you see a lot of
alignment
in us theoretically on a religious front
yeah the religion of it
you're curious on my what my take might
be in a couple things that you're
pondering with
yeah more or less cool makes sense and
so i've given amber mentality
talks i've done all different types of
stuff so you want to build your world
around this
thesis well yeah so like i've i've
competed i've done that
and so i think my story is interesting
i've had one wife
kids one with cancer young age right oh
you've got all sorts of [ __ ] going on
and so it's it's my my perspective is
unique and special the good news is
honestly and i really believe this is
why i write
i mean i really think that's we listen
you've got like clear-cut things that
people would be interested in
i think everybody really does like i'm
seriously
fascinated by it like the most niche is
what wins
and the most niche thing is being a
person
just being alive just being [ __ ]
alive dude like like i don't know like
it's crazy my sister put a rock up her
nose
at six it is like an unbelievably
interesting
moment in her life like it's pretty
subtle compared to like one wife
you know leukemia yeah but you could go
all in on it right
you could yeah you know and so like
i'm i believe that by the way so i think
you have things that are more outwardly
obvious
right but yeah i mean like like
everybody's got ammo
they just don't think some of their
stuff yours is obviously interesting
yeah but i think i think everything's
actually interesting i think that's the
punch line of this whole game well yeah
i think to your point like i just want
to get the message out in a different
way so
for years i messaged fitness and and
teaching movement i'm a subject control
expert in this
particular field of fitness so look i've
captured enough already you're going to
like this it's going to get to like the
more like
i understand i think already so let me
ask you a real question really i think i
do
i think you do too i think so
so are you trying to get as much
awareness as possible to then just give
you leverage to do whatever may come up
in your ambitions
yeah and you believe that that is
through building more personal brand
awareness
yeah good i think and so where do you
where do you sit
in the world that i sit in like how far
along are you
in the journey the journey is you
obviously
that's fine i think instagram not bad
so so and so where do you sit in this
whole lexicon
i mean so right now so i i mean
so when he first started i helped him
you know basically put the paint on
first
walls the first gym yes and so with him
for a few years instead of doing my own
thing
long story short came back yes now help
him out with apparel
and his personal brand outside the
company i understand yeah and so um
you're the business partner you're the
business teammate
of him yeah yeah that's right i
understand and so where is that right
now is that he created this huge
following
back in the day and where
so youtube facebook instagram his his
channels blew up immediately
because he had just went across the
games people want to start following him
yeah of course it was skyrocketing right
and but you were taking all that energy
and putting into the gyms
instead of the brand makes sense it's
2008. the awkwardness
so for example is that he has 50 000
followers on youtube
but we only get a few 100 hits on videos
so we're feeling just stale right now
we're trying to reactivate these you
know what's amazing
this will get you very excited
i don't think i was much further along
three and a half years ago when i got
serious yeah
like i had my thing i was winning good
things were happening
but i think i was at 48 000 subscribers
on youtube yeah
i was at 34 000 instagram followers like
i was
i was big on twitter because that's
where i come from right
but i was head down and building vayner
into like
i got rebooted drock started three years
ago i guess maybe 40 what do i mean 28.
i got rebooted somewhere in fourth like
three and a half four years ago
and it happened really fast um
so it's funny i think i was in a very
you know like
a lot of people like i'm in a very good
spot right now yeah
but like three and a half four years ago
i was in a stale spot
for a personal brand right
and that's and that to his point like
our cup the company's grown
yeah we and we have a brick and mortar
that's built on like
actual stuff right let me actually i
apologize for interrupting
what do you want let's say i go you got
25 million people
truly following you across the board
where do you think you're going to put
that attention
apparel no i think it would be speaking
engagements and sharing a message like
what you're doing
for me like especially my daughter being
sick has changed my whole mindset of my
perspective on things i've seen yeah
[ __ ] yeah and i think
i want to share the positivity i want to
i also want to share the message of hard
work
like i don't know whatever happened to
just good old roll up your sleeves and
just
crush it and like the way you start off
is
like dude i slept on the floor of our
gym multiple times and i don't know
where this and especially
the area it's so like ipo get rich quick
it just doesn't happen you have to keep
at it for a long time so
that's where you're at right you you you
you love speaking
yeah um okay
and so just to back up on the social you
know instagram
420 000 yep twitter facebook about a
hundred thousand each
excuse me for one second i'm just trying
to find us more time give me a couple
more minutes ago
keep going yeah so i mean between all
the different channels right
um there's different ways we make money
obviously but what i'm inspired by how
personal
so our gyms make money right we do about
a year in revenue it's great
so it's fine it's a real business it's a
real business right
we started a virtual business i don't i
don't live in silicon valley
mentality dollars and you know
in revenue from scratch is far more
impressive than 99 percent of the [ __ ]
i've seen
in silicon valley and that's one like i
don't really talk numbers much but i
know with you like i just want to share
with you real quick
give me context right context but so we
have that going on right cool next
trip right that's that right you feel
like that gives you the latitude of
investing in right
they have major sponsorship deals with
reebok that that pay my mortgage
but for me like my wife and i just did
an event this last
yesterday raised 400 grand for pediatric
cancer
because we know michael mina and
different chefs and brown all together
it's awesome
we're about philanthropic we're about to
share a message of hard work and being
positive
and that means that's the bigger picture
right and then everything works out and
then everything works out
like like then you get paid 150 000 to
give a speech right like
look then you get paid four million
dollars do i want to buy the jets of
course i want to buy the jets
but i also want to do good things along
the way for me do i want to send my kids
the best colleges so literally literally
like
a lot of similarities to where i'm at
hundred percent that's why one of one of
the reasons why
i followed up with you five six seven
times to my dude i really want to meet
you
and just share share who i am so look i
think
there's a lot of things running through
my mind i mean like you need to start
thinking of yourself as a media company
i'm sure you guys it seems like you know
enough about me to know there's nothing
i think i'm going to tell you that's
maybe not something you've ever heard
before
you need to have written audio and video
formed content
being put out at scale every [ __ ] you
have to understand
here's the thing it's a land grab is it
as
easy to become a crossfit celebrity
today as it was in 2008
no right supply and demand right the
supply and demand event
of awareness and attention in this
device across the 11 platforms
that matter will never be better than it
is right now right
and it's not as good as it was yesterday
right got it
so that's all i got to say from linkedin
corporate fitness content right to
[ __ ] a podcast
to all of it i think that you know if
you
how long have you been following me
years he's
he's decided to follow you for for a
long time good and you follow tim as
long then too
no got it i've been following both of
you guys for years good
so like and other people as well right
like if you watch who gets hot
who gets when who gets what like if you
look at the personalities that win
we're never in the same spot right this
guy jumps this one this girl jumps that
guy this guy goes down this guy goes up
it all happens based on who's best at
the thing that matters the most
at the time right like tim podcast
obviously he's crushing
that's right killing it and he's listen
tim is so talented dude
he's one of the best interviewers yeah
he's so talented i'm sure
he's so talented but moments in time
right instagram podcast you know
linkedin i'm very bullish on all this
stuff
like you have to have a podcast you have
to have written form you have to have a
vlog
you have to have like you have to have
them yeah so we just started a vlog
but we didn't want to bring camera in
here because we didn't feel like it was
appropriate um
just out of respect for you we're not
trying to show up always ask everybody
and as long as you ask kindly yeah like
for example i would have said yes
should have blocked your right hand we
should have been appropriate i'm just
giving you advice if you're going to do
a vlog
i overthink it too i i
almost didn't ask the rock last week but
then i did
and now we have it and that's good i
took a picture so you wrote your book
like
the guy looks like a dick until he's a
uh
all right right yeah yeah everything
looks right until right
until you until you don't right and that
was pretty funny
but for us anyway nonetheless you need
to think of yourself as a media company
you need to think yourself as espn not
as a person
and then then you start thinking
differently then you're like oh well
where's our blog
like the amount of content you should be
putting out and spending money on
my bigger thing is based on the two bit
two revenue streams for you that are
obviously more
more substantial the gyms and the
sponsorship
how is the crossfit community health
these days in relevance or has there
been so many new
new you know workout trends that are
kind of like that's what i feel in the
lexicon
yeah so we were we started off as norcal
crossfit
10 years ago as the years have gone by
three years ago we rebranded nc fit as
in norcal
fit right smart the reason for that is
we want to be in control of our own
brand period
i didn't want to be a temple yeah
anything you know
so we have the app with the gyms we have
the gyms with the
the partnership income right we have
t-shirts and apparel we have another
product we have just a workout mat
there's multiple avenues through the nc
fit through our company
that we make money from right long-term
contracts with corporate accounts
et cetera but the personal brand is
ramen inspired like so i want to share
the message so how can i help you
just meeting us yeah we asked each other
like like what are we going to ask like
i think we just wanted to come have a
conversation just yeah look listen
i don't think anybody understands how to
build a personal brand
on february 26 2018
better than me right this second
tomorrow i might see something
but like here's what i can tell you it's
about it's about
content at scale and really investing in
it
like you know forget about even your
guys relationship
what's the additional 300 000
all the way down to 30 000 that you you
know to me listening to your brand
three hundred thousand and four people
and add money
to take you to where you want i don't
have a good sense of
is that an expensive nut that's a lot of
money so i don't think like spending
three hundred thousand on your personal
brand is so easy regardless of
how well it's going but like when i get
like just listening
i would say hey hire four people at 50k
a pop
and spend a hundred thousand dollars or
three people at 50kpop and 150 000 in
instagram and youtube and podcast ads
and i think you'll be in a very like if
i tell you how to do it you'll be in a
really [ __ ] awesome spot in a year
where i think you can make up that
difference why the way you're thinking
about things the way we want to
like the nice thing is we have this
brick and mortar that's but now it's
time to
it's time to scale the personal brand
which i've been afraid to do for a long
time i get it
because when you put yourself out there
it feels uncomfortable yeah but once
once you make that
right once you can get to the
comfortable part it becomes the most
important thing
from a messaging perspective i do have a
question for you so you know you have
hustle there
i kind of i feel like two minutes right
like the hustle the push the
like this amara metabolic work hard and
it correlates with a lot of fitness
right like
translates really well even better
brother it's your truth
yeah you know here's my thing if dhh and
jason freed in silicon valley get mad at
me and write articles that i'm bad on
medium about hard work and it should be
about balance
that's their lives right like mazel tov
that you grew up in an ivy league home
and your parents paid for stanford and
like cool
that's and you should and i'm in
and you should here's what i know for
everybody that's like me
that grew up the way i did this is the
answer right
right so as far as messaging i don't
think about messaging
right that's how you get it right
brother that's the answer
right i overthink i mean everybody does
everybody does
february 26 2018 one reason i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm gonna speak my truth
all the way through and like i know i'm
a good dude
so i can't lose like i might not be
agreed on
i might not even be deemed right now
right but i have a funny feeling i know
how it ends dude well i mean you've
obviously you're proving the model
right now you're the industry leader
without a doubt like
and whenever you're industry leaders
some people are gonna be haters but [ __ ]
them
yeah and honestly i have empathy like
you know most people aren't gonna hate
on me if they know me at
all for real and if they don't like i
even have empathy like i don't know like
the video i just posted on instagram
like i was tough on that kid on stage
and like it feels like i was rude it was
just i could sense that i needed to be
rude
to help him right i just know what my
intent is right your intent is gonna be
able to pick up
do you know how many people in silicon
valley are friends san francisco like
people that you've worked with
use charity as a front to paint
themselves as a good person
you know which good [ __ ] i do that i
never talk about all of it i don't talk
about my family or my prof
or my charity work
doesn't mean i'm not doing it right like
but i'm okay with that because i always
say if an
expose comes and like people like show
us your tax report
we have to see it i'll be like here you
go right like that's how you know
so i don't overthink anything right
definitely don't overthink it
right if you're as good of a dude as you
think you are it all works out
i'm a i am authentic to who i am me too
man i got shortcomings like like you
know that's all it comes down to as long
as your shortcomings aren't like real
[ __ ]
right like that's that's why nobody
wants to build their brand
because they're harassing people because
they're stealing money because they're
doing dumb [ __ ]
right you don't really have no bad in
you no bad intentions
and you just put it all out there yeah
you're gonna end up somewhere good
that's why this is working for me i'm
growing because
the truth is winning more and more
right that's it that's putting out the
truth and how can people
you're gonna you as long as you're
putting out the truth and you have
self-confidence and you're patient
you're okay with people saying you're
full of [ __ ] right because i honestly
because a lot of people are telling you
yeah 100 i believe
and like you know like to me it's like
the aha at the end you know
like you win in the end right i don't
mind people booing me in the third
quarter
cool well we know you have a ton of
stuff to do really appreciate your time
yeah
it means a lot real pleasure i'll look
for your guys emails we'll talk we'll be
in touch we've got context now
[Music]
you